buona my friends of today storia lei in
the japan perché questa cosa è successa
in giappone esattamente come quella dei
marin che l'episodio precedente
guardaroba è successo in giappone vi
devo raccontare
partiamo per te che questa merita
ragazzi questa e risale a un po più di
tempo fa perché questa qua rispetto al
giappone le 2019 risale invece a quello
del 2016 quando andai per la prima volta
in giappone
c'erano anche email siamo andati ragazzi
nel 2016 in giappone siamo rimasti in
tre settimane li e stato un viaggio
bellissimo e noi abbiamo sempre fatto
coincidere insomma le date per il
giappone con l'ultra japan
ok con i mezzi abbia sempre fatto questa
cosa che cos'è la japan nutra japan
ragazzi è un evento di musica e di m e
lo fanno una volta l'anno ed è
praticamente una sorta di tomorrowland
non sono spiegati come un po più molto
più piccolo molto molto figo è un
festival
diamo al festival aspettiamo in sé dj
favoriti j ci siamo divertiti un sacco
stata una grandissima serata lì al
festival c'erano anche erano tutti i
ragazzi ovviamente giapponesi tutti i
ragazzi e ragazze abbiamo conosciuto
fama delle ragazze giapponesi tutte
molto simpatiche gentili e queste
ragazze giapponesi ci invitano a tutti
noi del gruppo a cena fuori il giorno
dopo siamo andati a questa cena tutto
buonissimo tutto figo le ragazze molto
carine o anche delle foto che
di farro scorre mentre che parlo tanto
la mia privacy ormai e dal 2000 è
qualcosa che non esiste più quindi vi
direi che posso anche mettere insomma
serata strafiga a un certo punto andiamo
al karaoke
ogni volta che parlo del giappone
finiamo in un karaoke norma ai ragazzi
perché il giappone fanno quello per
divertirsi e di giuro che è
divertentissimo quello del il karaoke
del giappone veramente divertente perché
la gente è presa bene c'è loro karaoke
come andare e come noi che andiamo in
discoteca praticamente non saprei
spiegarvela infatti del mio racconto
adesso vi faccio sentire la vera perde
di tutto questo racconto che è la
seguente
andiamo in questo pub dai pub in
giappone sono parecchio strani per che
cos'è che succede succede che tu entri
in un edificio
ok un condominio in condominio e in
questo condominio c'è l'ascensore c'è il
piano 1 massaggi piano 2 palestra briano
3 orto botanico piano quattro fab
cioè ci sono dei condomini dove ci sono
ogni piano c'è una roba che non c'entra
col piano di sotto e quindi questa cosa
molto strana e niente c'è la stowe pub
che era tipo al quarto piano di stock
palazzo era e lampade bellissimo tra
l'altro cento entrare lì ben sembra
varie sembrava che quella scelta che
fosse un portale per un altro mondo
praticamente entriamo in questo pub
molto molto carino
a un certo punto si beve si beve si
parla e si beve si parla e si beve
ancora e si beve tantissimo se bevuto un
sacco ragazza un certo punto una di
queste ragazze giapponesi mi collassa
addosso e inizia ad abbracciarmi e
questa e questo è il pezzo di video
quindi dico karate in realtà questo
video è raggiante uscito su questo
canale
andate a vedervi quel video perché un po
di riprese ci sono soprattutto questa
dove c'è la tipa che mi collassa addosso
una gran botta di culo va beh insomma
diciamo avanti
il tutto sto casino a un certo punto ci
troviamo tutti mega mega mega mega
ubriachi finché non succede una cosa
incredibile
eravamo tutti quanti abbastanza cioè
poco sobri ma certo punto arriva
giuseppe tutto il panic ato ragazzi
fermi tutti va da ognuno di noi che
eravamo un po sparsi per il pub ognuno
di ognuno sta rimorchiata da ognuno di
noi e ci fa quanti soldi ai 10 mila yen
che sono tipo 70 euro 10 mila yen
giuseppe e da melita bilico come da me
l'istat ha nelle gambe di vecchie lire
ad atti di sorprese i miei 10 mila yen
che vada surreal power iva su religiose
dimmi quanti soldi psycho e 20.000 yen
da meda merico e dammeli stefano quanti
soldi a york ha raccattato soldi da
tutti alla fine è riuscito un gruzzolo
di 80.000 yen più o meno una roba del
genere tipo 700 euro li mette lì sul
tavolo riguarda e si mette le mani nei
capelli
se io chiuse ma che cacchio stai facendo
non ragazzi non bastano i soldi non
bastano ma non possono per cosa
non bastano per pagare il conto e
ragazzi le tipe hanno ordinato 8 dom
perignon
sapete cosa vuol dire don perignon costa
tantissimo loro non ordinati 8 hanno
fatto legare otto bottiglie
no io ti ammazzo le tipe ubriache aveva
continuato a ordinare don perignon fino
a farci spendere più o meno 1.500 euro
ora siccome siamo
eravamo io io su riva ea meta in cinque
quindi fai a più tudor forse c'era punto
in sei quindi fai 1.500 euro perché alla
fine facciamo calcoli euro diviso 6
fanno questo attesta 250 euro a testa
che io ho ripreso la faccia in giuseppe
giuseppe sport chrono riguardano i
capelli sono slittati così perché o ci
ho ripensato alla fine
niente mi andati al pub perché poi in
giuseppe ha dovuto pagare con la carta
perché non ci arrivava usciamo poi tutta
allegria stefano comitato per terra
perché ubriaco io io piangevo cesserà di
me ma non è vero la tache divertiti sono
passato per il conto però insomma non
uscite con delle giapponesi si è andati
a tokyo perché non è il caso
io non è non fa non fatelo non è il caso
sfidate questa era quella volta non so
neanche come quella volta che la
giapponese di fotte 250 euro e io non
volevo neanche essere linee avanti la
vita continua
queste sono esperienze che ti segnano
soprattutto il portafoglio
dov'è il mio portafoglio
[Musica]